[Music]
welcome to the program that was exciting
what a great opening to the show you all
see the oscars last night
did you see angelina jolie stick her leg
out did you all see that
i haven't seen a skinny white leg like
that since i looked down in the shower
oh
if i had a leg though that looked like
that i'd never leave the house
he's stroking his leg again get out
well it would be markedly shorter than
the other one too so i'm just gonna
circle i'm walking short yeah exactly
whatever i said circles and circles yeah
yeah little drinky poo before the showy
poo
last night the artist won five oscars
yeah
yeah i thought about it that works out
to one oscar for every person who saw
the movie
[Applause]
who saw
who saw that film seriously a hand goes
up quietly
like the movie you are silent that's
nice i did
it wasn't there was inspire inspiring
moments so uh last night 82 year old
christopher plummer became the oldest
actor ever to win an academy award 82
82.
of course uh
when the show started he was only 79.
it was a long show
that was for me uh
hey listen to this gang
last night the oscar for best foreign
film went to a movie from iran
yeah
unfortunately as soon as the oscar
statue was sent back to iran it will be
stoned to death for being naked
you don't allow that there
except they do it with gravel
what's that so tiny oh tiny yeah yeah oh
okay
i like how you acted that out it's very
precise
get him i'll kill you yeah
how you doing infidel
another big international story
the house in pakistan where osama bin
laden was killed has been demolished
yeah
yeah but uh but not before each member
of seal team six was allowed to bring
one date
there's imagine
that's a date that would go very we want
to see something
come here
[Music]
that was me
so romantic yeah
first we fly to pakistan
then visit a bloody compound
big republican primary tomorrow
yeah as of tomorrow rick santorum will
be assigned secret service agents did
you know that
yeah this is historic it's the first
time santorum has agreed to use any kind
of protection
[Applause]
[Music]
uh this is exciting news bill clinton
former president bill clinton has been
named a nominee for this year's nobel
peace prize
yeah this will be his first trip to
sweden that he can actually tell hillary
about
[Music]
a spokesman for ben and jerry's
has apologized for creating an asian
themed ice cream called taste the
linsanity
yeah unfortunately he apologized by
saying me so sorry
[Applause]